I do think politics is very funny and I
think politicians are funny but and the
fundamental reason I think it is that
there it's all based on a huge lie
kind of like professional sports is
based on the lie that it matters whether
this team wins or not it really doesn't
in the end we just accepted that it was
all just just kind of a silly
entertainment politics is based on the
lie that they actually care about you
you know and I say this I'm a deeply
cynical person and a libertarian and but
I've been watching politics it fairly
close for a long long time and in space
a fact nobody in Washington cares about
you I don't care which side of the aisle
and what they don't care about you they
care about keeping in the office you
know having whatever perks and powers
above that and they care about winning
you know and especially today in America
winning is much more important to
everybody than ever advancing any
particular agenda or ideology certainly
helping people is way down the list
because you could argue any given issue
both sides can tell you why it will help
you to do what they want you to do but
in the end I don't believe that's what
they are trying to do is the higher you
rise in politics the less likely it is
you're actually trying to help anybody
but yourself and your immediate you know
cohorts I don't think Trump supporters
did get conned I think they got what
they want they want a guy who I know I
know a number of Trump supporters people
who you would not necessarily guess
we're Trump supporters they're not all
white males and they're not all straight
white males but they support Donald
Trump they still do not so much I think
because they don't believe that he is
some kind of great statesman they don't
believe that he is well versed necessary
on you know all all the policy details
that a president should be versed on but
they think that he doesn't like what
they don't like and he pisses off people
that they want to be pissed off and
they're you know basically the the Trump
supporters a large part of it it wasn't
racism it wasn't second position
it was that to the to the you know the
people that they don't like the New York
Times The Washington Post the political
establishment in general MSNBC you know
they're tired of those people they got
mad and and so they voted for Trump and
his behavior since he got elected hasn't
really done anything I think to diminish
that that support for him I think when
the people who don't like Donald Trump
and I'm one of them
finally figure out that the way to beat
him isn't going to be to keep saying
he's a dope he doesn't know anything
he's you know but to find an alternative
person who will present something that
that you know that people who are kind
of resentful of Washington resentful of
the elite establishment support can
support but in an intelligent way and
then you know then they'll do better I
would love to see the Democratic Party
come up with a good a candidate who
could appeal to people in Wisconsin in
Michigan I would like to see him come up
with somebody who will represent more of
a threat to Trump but as so far it just
seems that it's kind of like the Hillary
campaign continued which consists of
saying he's an idiot
he's a sexist he's a dope you can't have
it you know and all the people who like
him say we don't care what you say about
him we like them because you don't like
them Donald Trump dosing the humor
impaired in that in that respect
and I think the easy psychoanalysis is
to say he didn't secure you know usually
when people cannot laugh at themselves
that's what I assume is what what's
causing that problem but I think maybe
he doesn't seem really to be that it's
he's really willing to be president
United States which you know he's
obviously not qualified to be so he's
obviously I think he doesn't have an
insecurity issue I think he just doesn't
have a sense of humor I really don't I
and and he is key yet he can be funny
that's the weird thing he goes when he
was on the doing his campaign rallies he
was way more entertaining than any of
the Republican candidates running
against them and way more entertaining
than Hillary Clinton
he was just entertaining but it was
mainly because he would just say any
damn thing and people like that I mean
people love that I wish we could find
somebody who could say any damn thing
and to be competent that would be a
great combination
however that is not I believe his
combination
[Music]